we're seeing all over the world droughts
like the very serious drought in
California the very serious drought in
San Paulo Brazil the very serious
droughts in Syria Iraq Iran Afghanistan
Yemen that are destabilizing those
countries we're seeing massive floods
like we saw in the Balkans last year or
the massive floods that we saw in Japan
we're seeing the upheaval of our own
winter weather system in New York with
this unbelievable amount of snow with
the polar front dipping so far south in
the United States at the same time that
Alaska is experiencing 40 degrees
fahrenheit above their normal
temperatures so a lot of derangement of
the climate system international so you
believe sustainable development is going
to become the central policy issue
framework for the next generation how
does that square with lack of jobs
deficits and such are they two sides of
the same coin well sustainable
development says that we need to combine
three things economic growth fairness
and environmental sustainability so it
says economic growth which we have by
and large it's not enough if it's only
for the top 1% if the income gaps are
widening not good enough and if it's
destroying the climate or the land or
the ocean chemistry not good enough so
sustainable developments like what you
did all right on the first homework
assignment but you turned out the course
is a lot harder than you thought because
you have to get three things not just
one thing right but that's the way we
have to go because we're on a collision
course with nature and our inequality in
our economy is widening we're not doing
the job to make the kind of economy we
really need sir let's switch back to
geopolitics for our last segment you
knew the late Russian opposition figure
Boris Nemtsov he was buried today he was
shot to death last week what are your
thoughts on his murder and what are your
thoughts on the type of legacy he leaves
behind in Russia in the early days when
I was working with the President
Gorbachev and President Yeltsin
that terrible crisis of the economy and
helping to get a market economy started
the Boris Nemtsov was one of the young
wonderful honest leaders in the country
and he stayed that way all along others
became corrupted by what is an awfully
lawless system sometimes but Boris
Nemtsov was always telling the truth and
he knew in recent weeks that telling the
truth could cost him his life as he told
people just before his death he thought
the Putin might go after him and it's
unbelievably tragic and dangerous what
we're seeing what's his legacy for the
opposition in Russia he will be
remembered of course as one of the
bravest figures of reform and the call
for democracy and the call for economic
freedom as well is a wonderful person
will reformers now be hesitant to speak
up or does this embolden them to do much
more I don't know if anyone's in bold
and everyone's frightened and the
situation is certainly not good and it's
dangerous but it's never going to be put
down entirely in rushes by itself has
put itself in a dangerous position it's
also reeling right now economically the
war in Ukraine obviously is horrendous
for Ukraine but it's been a big mistake
for Russia as well